was that sound data is the new oil
with Digital Data the aim is that once
it's put into the system it generates
information that feeds the entire system
without data it is impossible to have a
clear picture of a patient's medical
history to know how they've been treated
and to measure the results
today in an increasingly Digital World
especially in this post-covered context
there are new Solutions new applications
emerging for Digital Data
it's impossible to look at what has
happened in the last two years and not
draw some conclusions from this that
will benefit people who will use Health
Systems in the future
people are much more used to using
information technology in their daily
lives both medical professionals and
patients
it is essential that there is a much
more intense circulation of data and
that there is a much more effective
Exchange range of Health Data to ensure
that we have a true single Market in
healthcare a single Health Market with
free movement of people and free
movement of health services will only be
possible if the Health Data of all of us
is not restricted by borders
in this area having better data and more
data guarantees better decisions better
public policy and Regulatory decisions
which will benefit All European citizens
foreign